Hello, I'm Rena. Nice to meet you and thank you for clicking on this video. Today, I am going to
talk to you a little bit about asexuality, as well as aromanticism. And, I will be referring to two
articles on psych2go.net called, Asexual Orientation by Heather Rayburn, as well as Asexuality,
Aromantic and Everything In Between by Casey Hildago.
So, if you don't know what asexuality is already, according to asexuality.org, asexuality is
someone that doesn't experience any sexual attraction. But, just because someone doesn't
necessarily feel the attraction, doesn't mean that they can't have sex or engage in sexual
activities. As well as, it's not like they can't engage in romantic relationships either. That would
be with aromantic people.
Aromantics have no desire for romantic relationships. However, just because someone has no
desire for a romantic relationship, doesn't mean they can't form other relationships like platonic
relationships or relationships with their family. They're just not interested in maintaining a
relationship that has to do with romance. As it's still a very vague concept on is it considered an
actual orientation? Some people believe that it's not an orientation at all. They believe that it's
gender identity disorder called hypoactive sexual desire disorder, or HSDD.
There are a number of different studies that try to divulge deeper into the idea of asexuality. One
such study decided that they were going to divulge a little bit deeper into asexuality by polling
102 individuals online that identified as asexual. Through this, they were able to divide and
categorize asexual people as being aromantic and romantic.
If a person says that they're straight, it usually is implied that they're both heterosexual and
heteroromantic. Similarly, if a person identifies as gay, they're believed to be homosexual and
homoromantic. But, the thing with asexuality, as well as any other sexuality or romantic
orientation, is that you can be asexual and you can be panromantic. Or, you could be demisexual
and you could be biromantic. There's lots of different mixes and matches that you can be from
your sexual orientation and your romantic orientation.
I think, generally, the idea of asexuality and aromantics is very foreign. When you look into
society and you turn on the radio, or you turn on the television, there's a lot, a lot, a lot of songs
and TV shows and movies that are all about romance, and you know, the guy gets with the girl,
or the guy actually likes the guy in the end that doesn't really like the girl. Or, you know,
songs about sex. But, society pounds that into you and makes you feel like you need to like this
stuff. You want to get married, you want to have relationships with people, and you want to
cuddle and hold hands, and spend Valentine's Day with your boyfriend or your girlfriend. But,
not everyone's like that.
And, because of that, and because of the way that society pounds this onto you, a lot of ases and
aros tend to believe that they are broken, something is wrong with them, which is definitely not
the case. The other problem, of course, is a lot of people confuse asexuality with celibacy.
Celibacy is a choice that people make, not to have sex.
So, first of all, I want to ask you, have you ever heard of asexuality? Have you ever heard of
aromantics? And if you have, has it been out of the idea of like trees being asexuals? The other
question that I want to ask aro and ases, before you knew that you were asexual or aromantic, did
you believe that you were heterosexual and heteroromantic due to heteronormativity?
Comment below. Like this video. Give it a thumbsup if you enjoyed it. Comment. Subscribe.
Follow us on our social media sites: Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr. And, if you have any questions,
I will try and get back to you. Thank you so much for watching! Bye.
0:29:49.357,1193:02:47.295